today a stylist is gonna help us find a
perfect pair of underwear I put little
2-0 thought into buying my indoor I
think guys buy underwear and they just
wear the crap out of it I have
underwears from like when I was 16 I'm
hoping to learn to not be an underwear
holder I used to really just buy the
cheapest pack I could find I didn't
really put a lot of thought into style
one of the things I'm really nervous
about today is that we're gonna be doing
a professional photo shoot with the
underwear that we're trying on I'm gonna
try not to be shy about it but I'm
really nervous I'm Kelly Swanson I
design and manufacture men's underwear a
really good pair of underwear can truly
make somebody feel amazing it's the
first thing you put on it's the last
thing you take off it's often the last
priority on a guy's shopping list let's
help these guys find their perfect bear
hi I'm Zach I'm Kelly I really don't
have much like taste or class when it
comes to underwear this is a pair that I
usually wear they're pretty old and worn
now Oh kind of holes yes they're boxer
briefs for me they write up a lot so I
really want to get a pair of briefs what
is most important to you in a pair of
underwear I think I'm a more of a fun
guy I think boxer briefs are definitely
your style they'll provide that support
while still giving you full coverage is
there anything on the table that really
jumps out at you I mean these over here
cool I just maybe I don't know what do
you think Internet we recommend that
guys refresh their underwear drawer
every 12 months or so I think I found
the perfect pair for you Oh how do you
feel about wearing these this pair here
it's the briefs style that you're
looking for in this kind of classic
black really simple minimal look you're
the best part about this pair though is
the fabric it's actually made of nylon
it's a super light mesh look which is
perfect for that breathability and going
from
everyday use of the gym this feels like
you could flip it's made with an
antimicrobial fabric you can wear it all
day and not worry about sweater odor
they won't write up your leg definitely
give you that support you're looking for
there the trunks that you like and then
I think the star of the show is
definitely in the print awesome thank
you so much I guess I got to go do a
photo shoot now well you're gonna look
great in them so good luck thank you
[Music]
start
I do feel kind of exposed but I mean
that's what happens when you're shooting
your underwear
50 votes coming by
[Music]
as the photo shoot was going on I felt a
lot more comfortable especially being in
new underwear I don't think I would have
been able to do that in the old
underwear that I had previously I
learned that I can actually put a little
bit more thoughts whenever buying my
underwear I didn't realize how many
different types of fabrics and styles
you could get them in I really do love
these new underwear I'm gonna be wearing
the hell out of these I'm gonna be
wearing no shorts or no pants anymore I
think this is going to be my new look
[Music]